you
well I'd like to introduce Nick Durazo
an avid Matanikau Kanter a couple of
neuroscientists from Munich and they're
going to speak about something
neuroscience and Python and it will
introduce themselves thank you thank you
yes we're lab mates in the neuroscience
lab in Munich we want to every day we
use Python and we and we we get the
sense that we do something quite special
we want to share two new neuroscientists
why python is such a useful tool for
neuroscience especially in the beginning
when you're trying to select which
language to use it's all it's all kind
of intimidating and also for those who
already know Python what we do in
neuroscience so that you can get a
better appreciation of kind of why the
batteries included aspects of Python is
so attractive to us and then why it's
been such a such a great great tool
exactly
and let's start just by describing a
little bit what is this broad field of
neuroscience then they briefly a what we
trying to do is record and understand
the signals that are here on the brain
and link it with the behavior of the of
this act to understand better how we
process the information and how will you
process the reality well we introduced
ourselves with this slide my name is
Javier Martinez he's Nick DeVito so I
have been focused mainly in the
development of interface for different
kind of experiment related with the
memory consolidation especially during a
sleep in this picture you can grasp an
idea of my project this is the interface
where the experiments take place and the
rat the animal has to distinguish some
kind of others a consolidated in the
memory and afterward we we record the
signals from the brain and my project
I'm studying spatial perception housed
the sensory the sensory input becomes
some complex representation of our world
and to do that I decided reality system
for rats so that they could go to run
around a virtual
and we could use behavior tracking and
simultaneous brain recordings in order
to do to build a map of what they
perceive and be able to manipulate it in
real time in all parts of our projects
Python Python is there from presenting
the stimuli to our to our subjects to
analyzing the final data and every
machine and interface in between and in
order to do that we're going to start
from data collection from the beginning
and just kind of walk you through all
the steps of a typical behavior
cognitive type project and and just
showed different Python packages that
are involved in addition we're going to
show code snippets from every Python
package that's involved making this a
marathon tutorial about 20 Python
packages in about I think we've got 20
minutes left and yeah yeah it's kind of
hot or what we want to offer you like a
small window to the science to
neuroscience through pi to then the
first star is a of the story
stay collection recollection of the data
we have some hypotheses and we have to
design the experiments that could check
these hypotheses for that the fields
stop or step is the recollection of the
data cognitive neuroscience stimulates
the brain as a kind of function sensory
input goes in something happens in the
brain behavior comes out and so we can't
start studying it unless we're going to
put sensory input in and my thoughts got
a bunch of visual stimuli audio stimuli
all kinds of stimuli packages that have
standards standard standard ways to
display these things to a tour and to
our animals and to humans psycho PI is
probably the most popular one psycho Pi
comes with a lot of built-in visual
stimuli that are really common in visual
neuroscience packages a studies to do it
it's really easy to use you make a
window using its visuals
package you choose the stimulus that you
want to display and any parameters that
you need in this case we're putting in
the center of the screen and then you
build a while loop and give the draw
command and say draw the stimulus to
that window and then tell it to go to
your display that's a really great way
to be able to start building experiments
of course you don't just have to do
standard 2d things you can do custom
custom graphics as well Python has a few
few really nice 2d game engines pilot
and Pi game being the most popular I've
wrapped because they link to OpenGL I've
wrapped it with my own 3d OpenGL library
and use that to actually drive a real
time virtual reality system and people
say that Python is slow because it's
dynamic or whatever but because of the
modern OpenGL packaging system that's
underlying underlying everything you
just have to connect to some really high
performance stuff so my virtual reality
system is running in 360 Hertz but I
don't have to program in anything about
Python to do that it's the same you make
a window and then because it's an event
loop program you put you put your draw
command in an on draw function and then
just say run the app I want to give you
an idea of what this virtual reality
system kind of looks like you see a
video of a top-down video of me holding
a rat with a big arena on there I put
the rat onto a board that's hovering
above above the the floor of the arena
and he looks from one side to the other
and although we see a lot of mover from
his perspective it looks like there's a
big cliff down there and rats are really
cautious they don't like to jump off big
things so eventually when he decides to
jump off and run around he's gonna jump
off under the safe side we use
experiments like this when I was
designing the virtual reality system to
show that rats do perceive virtual
environments one of the first steps to
building a new setup in order to do some
interesting cognitive experiments yes
thanks
let me go back to the presentation yes
here we are in addition to to this kind
of visual stimulus sometimes we want to
interact to other sensory system Nick's
really work intensively with the visual
system in my case I try to work more
intensively with a with the other system
basically the smell and how the animal
processes this information and for that
we need some kind of system that
delivers the others the smells and to
deliver the reward and you can see our
solution here and the potential of
Python for that we have really nice
library which is the serial library by
serial that is it is able to control
this hardware that is based on the
famous board Arduino and control the
different valves for releasing the
others and releasing the the water to
the onion then the code is relatively
simple and well most probably you can
understand everything this is just the
definition of the of the serial port
call it Arduino and for sending a
message to to the Arduino board and
release for example in this case they
the water at the right part of the maze
is just sending a tank ultimate messaged
with the right command to receive
information from Arduino we have just to
call the read line function and get that
information and process it in the manner
only way that we we prefer paisios great
connecting to anything on your serial
port if you want to connect to something
on a network
pythons built in sockets module is
fantastic for that I have a 3d tracking
systems I use for my VR and for that I
need to receive XYZ position where is
the rats head I get that data over the
network I make a socket to say where I
should connect to and then use the
receive function to receive the data
pythons built instruct package is
fantastic for breaking down byte strings
into individual variables I can say that
this message has three floats
into three variables and that gets me
back into Python and working with Python
objects again which I find really
convenient we don't only build our own
custom hardware though a lot of lot of
the devices we use our commercial
devices and pythons so popular that that
a lot of a lot of companies are
supplying Python libraries to it even
our video projector the one I use for my
VR system it has a Python interface I
can turn it on and do all the settings
and even control when it's going to
display something directly from Python
some some some sometimes it's prefer
there's proprietary software when you
connect to device and they provide just
C headers but that's no problem - I
found C types and psyphon packages make
calling C functions from Python very
fairly simple as well you just say where
where the your C header file is which
functions you in a call and then you
make a Python function that calls the
function and then from there you're back
in Python being able to control all your
devices from one language gives you
opportunities that might not have seemed
obvious at first by being able to
control my projector and my 3d tracker
all in the same script I was able to
really easily build something new a 3d
scanner out of those two devices and for
that III scan any arena we put in which
allows us to put a virtual reality layer
on any maze or any labyrinth that we
have a really kind of cool application
as a clinic and indeed the convenience
of this of python is that you can work
at different levels no we have seen
really complex 3d tracking system but
sometimes you don't want to have the
disease thing or you don't need it for
your experiment but it's important
nonetheless to track the position of the
animal and you give different commands
depending on that position then for that
a we have a really cool bindings in
battle of the opencv system then this
allows us to track the animal with
really simple commands I will I will
just explain a little bit dismembered a
calling OpenCV and tell him to the
device from which it has to capture
which in this case is a website a web
web can
well from the webcam basically what this
lines does is generating a model of the
background to subtract from every single
frame that we that we are quite from the
from the webcam we process it a little
bit just blurring and thrust holding it
and at the end we have a bunch of
clusters of pics of the chains from with
a perspective to this background and the
largest cluster in the in the arena is
our animal I will show you this video
which probably is more attractive to you
the video shows how the system is
performing we have our rat in this maze
this arena and you can see in the
largest cluster that they refer before
is the green area the dead rectangle is
just the direct angle that contains that
that cluster in this way we are able to
compute also thanks to open C be the
centroid of these of this area of this
large cluster and have a really good
estimation of the position of the animal
in the arena and this is really
important for for Neuroscience because a
lot of the encoding of the brain is
linked to the position in in the space
what we've done here is is I think
pretty amazing it's good normally you
pay about 2,000 euros to get a box that
has a bunch of buttons for for a
neuroscience lab like this and now you
can just put a webcam on it and then in
control your experiment that way that's
that opens up a lot of possibilities on
top of that we have more possibilities
because in a lab there are a lot of
people that are not linked to your
experiment are not related but
nonetheless at some or to some degree
have to work with your setup then and
not only that well it's also convenience
to you to convey all the information
that you are recording in a single bill
and the possibility of the packets of
the PI Q by Q T package to do this is
really powerful and this is just an
example of how to generate
window and add two buttons to the window
and solve the window here in this video
you can see the setup that that we use
in my experiments this is the same video
you said before but now integrated in
the user interface you can see a bunch
of data this is the communication with
Arduino through the serial port that I
mentioned before this is the one I play
this is the the signal from ultrasonic
microphone in the in the room to see
what is happening whether the animal is
vocalizing this is the information about
the leaking of the animal in the reward
and we know how eager is the animal to -
all how engages in the in the task and
this is the speed as you can see it's
really powerful to have this tool to
have this package that in a relatively
easy way allows you to to have this and
at this point here we are we have our
setup ready to be used we have our
subject we have nine signals we have the
animal moving controlling everything
thanks to Python so we can publish and
know this is a data analysis conference
we have to do something in between them
all right fine ok so we have to analyze
data we've got a lot of data well you
know it's not going to be very useful to
analyze our data if we can't get our
data into Python in the first place I'm
so so glad that Python has a bunch of
packages for for reading the data of
course the best thing is if you can see
the data while you're programming in it
spider and Jupiter allow interactive
data workflows that make make doing data
analysis really convenient you can even
try out a few lines you can see what's
inside your variables you can even see
that the plots that are generated from
the code next to the code next to the
formulas and documentation and links to
the to the the whatever is rid of
resources to explain why you did it
being able to document your
process while you're doing it is
credibly valuable especially the you
Peter notebooks is really cool when you
are working in a large lab when you have
to interact with many people and so
results to supervisor or the colleagues
you know
oh yeah no easy way yeah absolutely what
about this what about this
well Python has a lot of data reading
programs not only for neuroscience
specific specific data like the neo
package which has a bunch of
electrophysiology data reading reading
functions also there's a big big program
we want to advertise called open EF is a
group that is building open and open
source amplifiers for collecting EFA's
data really cheaply and really quickly
and they provide of course a Python
interface pandas lets you read in data
tables into data frames from all kinds
of formats and that's usually just a
simple read function you can connect to
any relational database through pandas
and sequel alchemy and even just save
your Python objects to load them later
through pythons built-in pickle package
loading dumping the data and loading it
reading it loading it usually you just
have to look forward in those words and
you've got your data inside Python
that's really fantastic exactly and once
we have the data we need something
powerful to process it and this is a bit
of scaring having I'm here having
listening is really nice because
listening Travis just today I also
realized and you probably know the
advantages but basically numpy what
provide is really powerful tool to work
with in dimension and matrices and this
really fit some mental schemes that you
might have through linear algebra or
through working really high dimensional
data in our case the data is could be
single as three dimensional like time
voltage and channels that we have but at
the end we have much more dimension that
the number of animals we transform into
the Fourier domain and we have many more
then numpy is really powerful working
with long
a large amount of data a power into the
to the square is really easy task
reshape it which is really convenient
when you work with a different kind of
dimension and you want to tour this to
change the shape of your matrix for
doing some computation is also a real
easy task and it's really powerful to
select in which dimension you want to
work yes using these this label and it's
even more powerful I mean you can do a
lot of linear algebra like computing the
the covariance matrix in a set of
features of the spike from the brain and
computing the similar value the
composition to get some kind of PCA and
on top of that is pandas isn't it that
provides a really powerful interface
when you work with data frames or time
series which is a mainly our case yeah I
love that pandas and there's working
with pandas always keeps your data
labelled it just you come back to your
analysis and you still understand what
you did yeah but we need more or even
portable powerful computations not so
and so yeah because the brain works at
different rhythms it's really important
to work in the in the spectral domain
for us then for that we have a type I
especially the signal processing a
package or library that allows this is a
simple example but you can do tons of
operations related with the way for your
transfer and so on this is an example of
a filter no I mean we won we have really
noisy signal here and we want to field
we want to filter it here and we want to
filter and we select the filter band
with between 120 220 Hertz because
that's really interesting especially in
the hippocampus in the brain but that's
another topic we can easily generate a
booter Butterworth filter
with the different parameters and just
calling the filled fields in signal we
can have this smooth version of the
noisy data where that conveys the
information we are looking for and we
collect a lot of data and a lot the
times of an important step is to find
out what which features are important
exactly and the features that are
important
well for that we need some machine
learning there we have the scikit-learn
which is huge I really love it
appreciate it and we saw easy example of
a linear interpolation here but the
point is that you can do really
supervised and supervised learning as
you may know and it's really cool that
more or less the procedure to to use it
is kind of similar in depending of the
algorithm that you do want to use
because you have to select the proper
model from the library and generate the
model and once you have the model just
call this function fit using your data
or the data you want to fit to that
model and that's all you can this is an
example of a different weight of the
animals while doing the task do three
days and as you can see some animals
really are correlated the losing of
weight with the learning capacities of
the animal and some animals not why I
don't know but is super powerful and I
really like this this in way of the
procedural way of of doing the the
different computations side by side by
stats is a really powerful statistical
packages all it's essential for doing
statistics in order to find out that if
the patterns you found are actually
significant it supplies all the basics
stop statistical functions that you
would want to do your t-test functions
there you're no other functions there
and watham just simple was supplying a
list or usually
and being able to find out when your
p-value is when it's a physical value is
really convenient of course it also has
all the statistical distributions built
in in a common interface between all of
them so that if you find out your data
isn't normally distributed or it's
actually a binomial or gamma
distribution you can just change a
single line and all of your code will
still work you can simulate new data and
you can use that to to to to analyze
your day that little better stats models
allows you to use an are like
statistical equation a language called
Patsey which lets you lets you describe
more complicated models and see the
relationships between all of them
being able to just say what kind of
model you would have fitted and give a
summary of how all those and know it's
time to show the results oh yeah
python has a lot of data visualization
packages most of them are built on top
of matplotlib a really a great low-level
matlab like interface that lets you let
you build build any kind of thought you
want for example this is a jump trace on
the top right right hand we can see it
you can actually see the rat jumping off
the board onto it onto the Seabourn lets
you build
if you're going to build build a complex
plot though there's there are a lot of
kind of mistakes you could make that
that may they may prevent you from being
able to maybe build something that's
easily interpretable and Seabourn and
provides a lot of single functions that
let you build complex fantastic plots
that are built on top of map 11 because
they're built on a pot lid you can
customize those Seabourn thoughts to to
to edit it the way you want to represent
your data being able to to load in your
data transform it and then see what that
looks like graphically in a rapid rapid
fashion lets you iterate quickly and get
to get to the essential core of what
your data is representing exactly and
now at this point okay now we are ready
to publish we went through the whole
process
thanks to Python translate this
wonderful ecosystem of libraries and we
are ready to submit our paper achieve
then the message that we want to convey
here is that Python has a rich ecosystem
of packages from the for all the people
but especially for newer scientists and
this is an advice maybe for for people
starting their studies that they can
really use Python for wide range of
tasks in the neuroscience field and in
science in general and that is really
really convenient we have so how many
package we've shown more than twenty
already okay - is the programming
language in the end just like any
programming language but and like any
programming language you can do whatever
you want with it
what makes Python so useful for
scientists is how how easy to read the
languages and more importantly how big
the scientific community is you have
developers building tools for scientists
and a language they like working with
and scientists building tools using
those tools and improving them
themselves having those two groups
together always interacting
always always learning together and
always advertising and being able to to
share their work in an open-source
fashion is what makes Python such a
great community beyond just a tool
exactly and this is the this is the
question no we were talking we were
discussing why Python has so many
results basically the answer that we
will reach is because of you the
community is the important part not only
scientific but the whole Python
community because basically you develop
you have to develop you are engaged in
improving the quality of the packages
and the our goal or messages let's keep
working on this let's improve the
communication between scientific
industry companies local communities
international communities everybody to
increase the quality of the of the
packages and they see the availability
of the packages yeah that's right so we
can do more interesting and more
scientific research and that's why we
thank you to all of you for coming here
for these two the organizer especially
for these great talks and finally the
people who helped us for being here our
supervisor professor Anton syrota
we lead a really cool a new science lab
the CNS and the synergy clustered in
Munich that provides some funding and of
course the organization of the PI data
conference here in Barcelona of course
to all of you for being here for invest
your time and listen to us thank you
very much
No well if you have any question feel
free eating that is wrong first of all I
would like to say that that was an
amazing talk really it was very easy and
and was very well organized and if I
will you would have company I would hi
and for sure this is recorded yeah yeah
someone should listen about that I am
also a researcher so I really appreciate
that the work that you are doing and I
would like to know if you also are
working with functional magnetic
resonance imaging and if you and if you
also how if there exists some packages
for for treating that kind of images or
something I've worked with some MRI data
in in Python I get the die PI D i py
package has has a lot of tools already
for doing diffusion tensor imaging and
loading and visualizing MRI data the a
great resource for finding more more
Python packages for scientific uses is
Syfy's topical software page you can
look up your look up your field and
it'll it provides a great curated list
of packages that are available and
you'll probably find a few great ones
there Thanks
thanks thanks for the talk it was very
very entertaining I have one question I
mean to be able to do the kind of things
that you are doing with all these
packages you have to invest a
non-negligible amount of time mastering
them and you're doing your research on
top of that and the question is how do
you manage and aren't you afraid that
you'd eventually get sucked away from
neuroscience and end up being just a
plain developer like most of us what
you're doing is super cool so you should
keep at it right so but I'm interested
in how you you have no that divide
between all the effort you have to put
into doing all these cool Python things
and sticking to your to your research
that's a great question and that comes
and that does come up in our discussions
in the lab the key seems to be education
and basic programming principles and
good practices when you have to figure
out programming all by yourself at the
computer from scratch it is a lot of
effort but but if you have a course or a
workshop available by someone who can
take you through those first steps being
able to run a script being able to
organize your code and actually getting
you to write a few functions so that you
understand about the principles of
reusable code it cuts down that time
dramatically so so pythons pythons
active community has been very helpful
in in smoothing that learning process of
course the Python language is made to be
a learning language as well and it has
some built-in kind of features that help
you along that curve but we need more
yeah and I would like to say that of
course it's a great burden for for
newcomers well when you are starting the
bits that you are completely lost you
don't know well you start getting in
touch with the community is really nice
to have a community in your Institute or
the faculty where you are working then I
would suggest you if you try to can do
it do it because this interaction made
everything every that transition is here
much easier and in addition I will
the message to the api's of the world
please hire more computer science people
in the neuroscience I mean other
scientific fields because the anger
engineer in neurobiology department and
this interactions between different
fields increase the pace of science
increase the pace of the improvement of
the society because well many of you
probably are computer science you have
the knowledge about many of these these
things and this collaboration is
fundamental for ya but if you can help
if you work in a lab and you and you've
kind of gone through all that curve look
around at your lab mates and sit down
with them mentor them help guide them
through that process you'll help them
out quite a bit and you'll grow the
Python community so this is a tricky
project just a curiosity for how long
have you been working on this I have
been working for two years in this uni
I'm ending my PhD this year and that
means in neuroscience that usually means
about five years so this is my fifth
year we've done a lot of sub projects
that we're not showing at everything
that we've done within the PhD one of
the great things about about doing
science is that you're always challenged
with new questions new tasks or
something it doesn't work or works
better than you expect it and leaves you
in an unexpected direction and so it's
been a lot of fun and really exciting
yeah any more questions
so that was really a great talkers where
we enjoyed it that's kind of the same
question but what was the most
time-consuming thing you had to learn
for me writing writing this this 3d
wrapper around pilot and psycho pipe was
was challenged because I had I had to
learn how to write a good software stack
learning good object-oriented
programming design principles going
through going through all that all those
stumbling blocks deal with just books in
blogs blogs available took a lot of time
I had to I had to rewrite my library
three times but I and learning more and
more more on the way of course but it
was a time investment and also some well
sometimes their interaction with the
hardware could be complicated because
you have to be really aware of the
timings between the signals between the
hardware and your requirements I mean
the animals and the signal of the brains
move fast and you have to be really
accurate with the precision
thank you also for this amazing talk one
curious well one question that makes me
curious about your work is to ask it in
a Python way is there result in your
research that you couldn't have obtained
in the same amount of time
if you hadn't used Python or at all
these libraries available in my gaze or
several I would say if I didn't use or
if I have not used Python I will have to
use C++ which for me personally is much
more difficult for the data analysis I
think yeah I mean I could not have done
faster with other any other tool a lot
of the the the data the data analysis
problems were facing don't have
commercial solutions yet they're coming
I see everyone well we see we see X I
don't know neuroscientists who have
designed a solution in order to help to
help scientists be able to process their
data faster but the unusual nature of
every behavioral experiment means that
we have to build new equipment and we're
collecting it in a slightly different
way or in a slightly different format
yeah and you can kind of it kind of bug
yourself down in a new commercial
technology stack being comfortable with
Python take some of the stress away
because you know that even though you'll
have to deal with these things you don't
have to switch languages to do it and
that's lesson
let's phone the speaker's again thank
you very much